Peggy 18
[Music]
hello my name is Alex Amancio creative
director for Assassin's Creed unity
with a redesigned new game engine and
some revolutionary thinking from our
engineering and design teams we've
created an experience materially
different from anything we've designed
before with unity we've raised the bar
in terms of how we build worlds and how
you interact with them
unity is a truly immersive experience
revolutionised by new gen technologies
that affect the users experience at its
core
welcome to Paris at the height of the
French Revolution when you enter here
you'll see what our new animal game
engine has made possible it's in the
light and in the shadows it's even in
the air advance reflection mapping HDR
graphics and volumetric lighting and fog
fill each scene with drama and intensity
we filled Paris's iconic landmarks for
you to explore at a scale of nearly one
to one these immense structures are not
facades each is a fully realized
creation a world unto itself amongst
them is not redundant Bay a triumph of
digital architecture that required a
full year to design these seamless
exteriors and interiors are massive yet
intricately detailed
and our next-gen engine brings
non-player characters alive in a way
never before possible you'll interact
with thousands of Paris's inhabitants
from kings to paupers each rendered with
startling realism and each alive in
their own way these crowds can provide
you with valuable cover as you explore
the city but beware even non-player
characters have minds of their own and
may not behave as you're expecting to
because of the anvil technology at the
heart of the Unity experience things not
only look different they feel different
unity introduces a new breed of Master
Assassin more responsive agile and
lethal than its predecessors a
redesigned warrior and ready to take on
a redesigned universe
you'll find improve flexibility in the
parkour experience allowing you to
select different paths on the fly in all
three dimensions
[Music]
and we've upgraded the control mechanics
for more fluid interaction
unity brings you deeper stealth
mechanics as well unleashing an array of
new prey kill and disappear strategies
your fighting skills are refined
creating a more nuanced combat
experience as you battle enemies in a
bold 'end by advanced AI preparing dodge
and attack you'll find each encounter a
more accurate test of your abilities
unity challenges you to survive in a
daunting and violent world treacherous
and bloody but you need not enter it
alone now you and three of your friends
can band together in the shared
experience each playing apart for one of
history's most dangerous chapters
a radical new game engine
next-generation hardware and a massive
design team combined in a visceral and
unforgettable encounter with history
Assassin's Creed unity promises you a
whole new experience set in a world of
cinematic scope and enhanced reality
unlocking a new era of gaming
[Music]
we invite you to join us here
[Music]
you